welcome back to new rockstars we're
going to keep this jingle jangle
jingling uh with ring ting tingling too
we got a bite size question that we're
going to answer the best we can in one
bite of a santa claus okay our friend a
tripper on discord asks how does santa
claus deliver presents to children
all around the world in a single night
yes
a tripper from the football picks pool
hey tripper i recognize that name
a tripper very helpful tommy and i are
gonna try to answer this together
because you're right
even if santa who does exist were to
travel west with the rotation of the
earth as fast as he can
millions of households he would have to
hit would make it impossible for
someone like that to visit every house
in a single night yeah but i think
tommy and i have some theories on how
he's no normal mortal
i'll go first eric santa is a spirit
a jolly ghost the laws of physics do not
apply to him
he himself is a cosmic specter but the
toys he brings
are tangible and real so well he wow is
not
corporal being per se the toys are real
the joy is real that makes them even
more powerful tommy if you think about
it if you strike him down
he's a force ghost he is a force ghost
yes that's it but an even more powerful
force goes to isn't just in another
plane who you can communicate with he
can cross
over into the tangible realm and
produce toys yes that children's can
still play with
that's incredible he can cross over both
worlds
yeah he's like the ghosts in field of
dreams who can just go back and forth
over
the line he's like shoeless joe jackson
yeah do you think the people who
buy that farm are like do the ghosts
come with the corn
can we exercise the ghosts or is that
just the thing we have to have
if you build it he will come oh
hell no can we cut down the corn stalks
and sell them or are they gonna
be rid with that one of the ghosts made
my daughter buy him cocaine
is that actually that wasn't a ghost
that was a drifter
but he was very pale andres is a
baseball player he's a ghost now
he did all the cocaine in one sitting
okay uh kids
theory two even if uh santa was a
speedster like
the flash or quicksilver santa could not
physically move faster than the speed of
light otherwise he would disintegrate
so i'm thinking maybe he can create a
warp
bubble around himself that allows him to
teleport
through space-time from one house to
another house
essentially creating a rift in space
time a wormhole wrinkle in time
you bend you bend the sheet of paper and
you poke a hole through it that's what
santa does
you knock books off the shelf we've all
seen interstellar we get it murph
murph come on murph you can do this huh
smurf
decorate the dreamer that part is
shouldn't be that emotional and i cry
like a baby every time i watch it
because
because he's so worked up as an actor
that i'm like
it makes me emotional anyway point three
on our little dissertation what we know
as santa is actually a company called
santa society of altruistic knicks
throughout america
every neighborhood in the united states
has a different local santa a
representative of the santas if you will
this is the santa you see at the mall or
at santa's village
or the one who comes to your school or
the guy who comes home with your mom
after a friday night at the movies it
makes a little too much
noise and you come out into the hallway
and you say who are you and he goes
go to bed kid i'm santy claus that guy
papa tens of thousands of these santas
but only one jeff
and they're all oath swearing due paying
members of this proud
union their duties include present
delivery
letter and gift list reading and naughty
and nice sorting
their payment is cookies they elect a
santa chairman every year and there's
lots of politics involved
this year i hear there's a disputed
election where one santa won't concede
well
he's invited the elves from certain
certifying boards and swing states and
uh maybe one might flip there's a lot of
uh goblin
lawsuits those goblins are grossing it's
spot all over their goblins
yeah handkerchiefs and wipe it on them
that's right that's right
but before we continue thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and has zero calories
yet it tastes
great there's over 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those flavors is
black cherry vanilla
my favorite flavor if you love cherry if
you love vanilla and
you have a darkness inside your soul
this is the drink for you
because it'll totally energize that emo
side of you
check out bang on instagram you can get
25
off your order when you go to
bangenergy.com
use the code new rockstars25 there you
can buy cans of bang
energy including their sweet tea and
keto coffee flavors you can also
get clothing fitness supplements all
kinds of stuff to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
i have another theory i think that over
the years
many of santa's elves might have just
grown older
and uh chubbier let themselves go why
weren't you
at health practice they began to look
like singing
okay just kind of like how married
couples start to look like each other
that's what happens with these elves who
none of these things can die they're all
immortal so they just
as they get older they start to look
like santa's now he's got like hundreds
thousands of these things a big team
of santa plus a thousand and thousands
of thousands of santa looking elves and
they
all deliver the gifts in a fleet of
slaves
and then santa has them all dress up in
identical santa claus so that
no kid who happens to see them would
know which one is the true santa they
just all assume the real santas come to
their house
you sit on a throne of lies but because
santa's such a good guy
he always does a shift he always has an
undercover boss because each year
he he wants to do a different shift in a
different neighborhood and get to know
the whole world
i like that that's really nice option uh
five santa is like liberace and he
forces his lovers to get plastic surgery
to look just like him just kidding
that's not it
uh that was i just made that one up to
see who's paying attention
no number five santa is like zack morris
and can freeze time
but only on one night per year and not
to bully people the way zack used it
that's why you never see him actually
put the presents under the tree
the dilation is what accounts for the
tilt of the earth and the waning and
waxing day
length throughout the year it's all
those little time blips that's
that's what's making it happen if santa
didn't do this every christmas night
every day would be the same length
throughout the year so we actually owe
santa
for all those 4 30 it's dark outside
nights
that make me so depressed thanks causes
the seasons yeah
seasons don't cause santa it's kind of
like our theory about the night king and
game of thrones
yes that we thought like he came with
winter the winter is coming but no
his arrival is what brings winter with
that yeah that's what santa is he's the
night king
and he's gonna be stabbed to death by a
little girl cindy lou who she's gonna
pull a real cool move
with a dagger candy canes
candy canes lick him in a spear and kill
your enemies that's that steps that's
that's that's
well i think one of these must be the
plausible explanation i i don't i can't
think of any other
possibility in this that's gotta be it
that's gotta be true it's gotta be one
of those yeah
well happy holidays everyone kind happy
holidays from us at new rockstars to you
yeah we hope
wherever you are you're staying safe and
find a nice honey to shack up with hell
yeah
i'm gonna sleep with this thing
i like that you're inside it you have
been eaten by it and you're just
enjoying that it's digesting me the
juices
the juices so warm finally well thanks
tommy uh for joining me this episode
it's been great to chat about all this
with you you can make sure to follow
tommy
tommy bechtold follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars send us your big questions
using the hashtag bigquestions subscribe
to this podcast feed give us a nice
rating review subscribe to rockstars
here on youtube hit that notification
bell
because every time you do an angel gets
its wings and the boss family will shoot
it down from heaven
love it see you next time
[Music]
you